americans are losing faith fast in the
president who promised america freedom
from the virus joe biden's flailing in
the face of a new strain of covid and
not taking the possibility of new
lockdowns off the table his solutions
more the same doubling down on vaccines
and masks to stop the spread and here's
what he said just a few moments ago
this new variant is a cause of concern
but not a cause to panic
on thursday i'll put forward a detailed
strategy outlining how
we've gone we're going to fight this
covet this winter not with shutdowns and
lockdowns with more widespread
vaccination boosters testing and much
more
in the meantime
in the meantime the best protection is
getting fully vaccinated
getting a booster shot
i urge all americans who haven't yet to
get that done get it done today
we're going to keep fighting through
this and every tool we have but
americans aren't buying what joe biden's
selling when it comes to the pandemic
only 48 percent of voters thinks he's
done a good job with covid compared to
64 just six months ago
and then there's the big problems with
inflation and the supply chain crisis
that the white house has repeatedly
blamed on covid gensake has some new
spin to pass the buck
we're out there democrats in congress
are out there many of them we welcome
republican support i will continue to
say uh taking steps to lower costs what
is the republican plan for lowering
costs for addressing inflation something
they are very concerned about but they
don't seem to have any solutions for it
are you buying that spin ms farina well
like um i would say the republicans are
not for dumping a whole bunch more money
into the government that would actually
lead to inflation like that's a plan a
plan to not spend is still a plan you
know just because you're not adding more
money to the deficit or to the budget
doesn't mean that you don't have a plan
that that you do
i actually think that what president
biden has done in the past couple days
is pretty good right he said we're not
going to go back to lockdowns i think he
knows that that's one not necessary but
also politically untenable
because he maxed out on his coveted
credit card right and now he wants to
continue to swipe it but everyone's like
no you're you're maxed out
you don't have any more room to run on
that plus things are different now to
his point we have vaccines he doesn't
bring up the fact that a couple of the
companies maybe even three now have a
therapeutic pill yeah that can be used
for treatment plus we're still waiting
to find out more about the omicron
variant it could be that it is more
transmissible but less
deadly and possibly have mild side
effects for people so that that means
that more of us get immunity and we can
move on with our lives from there what
are these new things that are going to
be in this plan do you think thursday
greg i don't know you know whenever i
talk in absolutes i'm a hundred percent
wrong
well at least you're consistent
anyway this all comes down to good faith
uh it is do you believe that the leader
operates in good faith under similar
circumstances and he hasn't you know he
he spread lies when he was running for
president about the vaccine he allowed
violence to unfold because he knew that
it would hurt the red republicans he
never really cared about the american
people he cared about his parties so he
had no issue with labeling half of
america as racists or deplorables or
whatever he called them the fact is uh
you can't trust him he's disconnected
from reality uh
he's exempting federal workers from the
restrictions that he's applying to
everyone else again that's an unlevel
playing field he is not a unifier my
point is if we thought he was operating
in good faith and that he was
cognitively capable we'd probably be
okay with him but there's too many
mistakes that he's made and this is this
is a huge the pandemic is probably one
of the biggest recent problems in
history and crisis is make the leader
but what if the leader is so
disconnected that he can't be trusted to
make sound decisions i don't believe
he's capable of making sound decisions
because i've been watching this guy
makes mr magoo look like winston
churchill so forgive me uh if i'm just
like i'm not there for this and i think
to to you to your point which is
everybody's saying now do you notice
that to your point yes um what was i
going to say
think about what her point was that he's
overused the covid credit card and i
think that we've had enough the idea of
a shutdown ain't going to happen you do
another shutdown there's going to be
there's going to be actual you know
credible resistance not the kind of
hashtag resistance you saw when trump
was elected this stuff will be for real
so that's not on the table and emily his
vax mandate got shot down by the court
and then he just delayed his federal fax
mandate until after the holidays so it's
kind of everything he's done has been
defanged
absolutely but to hear him talk about it
you would think that it hasn't and
remember to your point about him being
full of
hot air
that remember back in march when he was
a candidate and he said no wall stops
the coronavirus no travel ban stops the
coronavirus cut two all that has changed
is who is sitting in the white house
because according to him
well all that has changed is sitting in
the white house but the policy is
exactly the same but back then it was
xenophobic and now it's working for some
reason yeah and you know bringing up now
that he said well i'm pushing back any
type of punitive behavior or punitive
repercussions to these people in the in
the military who are choosing not to be
vaccinated right now there's a
tremendous fight going on between the
national guard and the pentagon under
his watch under his direction and those
guys aren't going to get paid and just
today they were going back and forth
with the press secretary of the pentagon
saying they're not going to get paid
they're not going to do operations and
that's a real threat to those families
who are trying to earn their livelihoods
and put food on the table and that's
just one more disconnect that his credit
card has been uh sort of overused by and
that we see right through him and he
can't even get the name right by the way
he was calling it omnicron i don't blame
him
that sounds like a marvelous
a marvel character he's a problem
he's president of france
all right geraldo your thoughts well my
thoughts are i think that the the
analysis so far has been very harsh and
partisan of president biden i think that
he has taken the best steps he possibly
can given the fact he doesn't know very
much but by saying no new lockdowns i
think that's a very important moderation
it hasn't worked to calm the markets we
had another awful day today that's two
out of three so we're down well over a
thousand points
since friday
but i also think you know having just
returned from the newly independent
republic of barbados of course as you
know over the weekend uh they
you know they don't have a travel ban
you come into the country uh you get you
have to show your proof of vaccine
a vaccination and an up-to-date
vaccination and you have to take a test
that i think is the key to life
show proof of vaccine
take a test and go wherever you want to
that's the key to allah i think that
travel bans are ridiculously disruptive
uh we we we've seen that proven time and
time again well they worked with china
which if they work in a communist
repressive country where they know they
worked when we hit china
geraldo fauci said it saved hundreds of
thousands if not millions of lives they
do work you have to admit
i think that travel bans are ridiculous
i think national boundaries are
arbitrarily drawn
when you start when you start saying
that you can go from vermont to new
hampshire i mean what the hell are you
talking about but instead you want
people to show their papers i want
people to show that they're vaccinated
but i mean to have a travel ban but have
our southern border completely wide open
does seem a little ridiculous yeah
that's when we're gonna know that
biden's taking this threat seriously
when he closes the southern border any
more ridiculous commentary geraldo
are you done
metaphor and we would like you to
everybody
brace yourself brace yourselves uh i i
think that you've got to give the guy a
few days to get his uh his arms around
this new variant let's see
honestly and you want to see golden
respect you want to see what this thing
is all about and whether we should be
you know in a panic about it i hope not
i don't think so i think that the cases
that have been uh presented so far has
been relatively relatively mild i don't
think there'll be a big spike in
hospitalizations i think all eyes should
be on hospitals though when that starts
ticking up then we'll know that there's
real fear behind this omicron okay well
it would help i think if he
redirected some of his anger away from
the american people and hit china with
some of that maybe that would help with
the goodwill greg was talking about you
know confront china hold china china
have to do it what does china have to do
with the china virus today you know you
should have stayed in barbados yes yes i
thought i thought this came from africa
next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else